taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food welcome to
t-a-s-t-e budge buddies Tasties whatever
you call yourself these days
Joe DeRosa here with the taste buds
podcast uh my sweetie pie Sal vulcano is
not here because those damn Jokers are
at it again they're shooting their
pranks all around the city today God
knows where they are God knows what
they're doing to some poor unsuspecting
citizen
but in his Stead
I have
a new friend but a dear friend we've
shared a lot together in a short period
of time my man cujin how are we doing
what's up Bob thanks for having me
thanks for being here long time coming
yeah I know we finally got you on the
show yeah it's been a little bit I love
it
I love having here we have another guest
coming in he's not here yet but he is
coming and also by the way here is where
we're at Joey roses we're in the RV
outside yeah where we have our outdoor
seating uh it is National sandwich day
better than that yeah that's today's
topic is we're going to talk sandwiches
for National sandwich it's a food
podcast I own a sandwich shop why would
we not do a full sandwich episode you
got it well we just talk about the
greatness of sandwiches [ __ ] love
them for me every day is National
sandwich day right other people need to
be reminded
what's your favorite
wait what'd you do this morning you went
I was on pix 11. there was just like
National sandwich day you know
we just talk sandwiches kind of they
made a sandwich for me what'd they make
you they had like some cold cuts they
had 45 seconds to make it they threw it
on there a little dry
was it good [ __ ] bloated already it
was all right
what what what would they throw on it
hey true like turkey provolone roasted
red peppers a little mayo the bread
sucked but they already knew that so I
was like all right I'm coming to Joey
roses after
yeah you get a real sandwich for eight
dollars by the way what the [ __ ] is that
about not every sandwich is eight
dollars the original eight or eight
dollars because we opened during a
pandemic
a pandemic the pandemic the one that
we've experienced the first of many
but we opened on the pandemic and the
whole idea was we and and also too we
just wanted to have something in New
York that was affordable again
uh and we said we were gonna you know
stick with that when we went into the
brick and mortar now the newer
sandwiches are costing a little bit more
money
you know what I mean got up the price
when I pay taxes yeah sometimes yeah
that's great do I do I represent
sandwiches
you think the coach and Joe I think
yeah yeah I got my piece of the pie on
it I think
I never imagined it you know I was just
schmuck in that car chowing down on
sandwiches taking small bites but here I
am Joe the Rosa Joey roses ate dollar
sandwiches and I'm [ __ ] on them
[ __ ] cheap and Daughtry you gotta up
the prices cuz the new ones do cost more
what are they 8.25
kind of Bring It's like you got to bring
Jordan on the makeup for the other guys
you know what I mean you gotta look for
nickels on the street
we're we're really pushing today for
National sandwich day we launched or or
made the formal announcement of our two
new sandwiches
and this is called the we got two new
vegetarian sandwiches get into that
market yeah so the Cameron shut up you
gotta you gotta have the Cairns aren't
vegetarians I got news for you yeah
yeah
but uh but uh this is called the sink
because it's like the kitchen sink
everything but the kitchen sink it's all
kinds of pickle toppings uh with uh
Asiago and provolone cheese on it and
this is all three cheeses Asiago
provolone
an American and this is tomato onion and
hot and sweet peppers this is more like
a hoagie like a cheese Hoagie yeah which
I love cheese hoagies growing up so I
wanted to do something like that yeah
yeah I loved all Hoagies but I never got
a cheese sandwich going I mean grilled
cheese but never ever
Knock You backwards but anyway we're
doing a contest with the fans you can
vote in the DMS and comments on Joey
Rose's uh a heartache as our Instagram
Joey Rose is Hard Eight you can vote for
Which sandwich stays on the menu come in
you try it whatever blah blah blah so
anyway I have these out today for us to
eat them for National sandwich day but
we're not here to talk Joey roses we're
here to talk taste buds and do the show
you know what I mean right sometimes
it's a little cross promotion I got
taste buds fans inside we got a couple I
think in the RV right now a couple
haystones
hey what's up what's up guys
yeah yeah yeah we didn't make a huge
announcement but we leaked out that we
might be in here and here they are
oh nice
flowers down here there'd be a line you
know
you know you're not getting rubbed in my
face every three minutes how much more
famous this kid is than me
[Laughter]
what's up Instagram Tasties taste buds
good to see you guys what's going on we
got cuisine in the house man and we got
another special guest on the way to the
RV it's going to be a lot of fun today
we're talking National sandwich day now
you were at what was it called systolic
13 where were you this morning oh yeah
yeah your sister said picks 11. I don't
have any sisters thank God pixel 11
pixel pix what is it what am I a [ __ ]
literature teacher
it's like a news thing I think it's a
New York thing and uh you know I was
just talking sandwiches for a few
minutes this is the most I've ever heard
you speak but yeah I don't really talk
much you know a lot of people like you
guys got to be you're probably the life
of the party now I sit in the corner and
just drink my sorrows away yeah no yeah
you're a real quiet kid in real life
yeah you know took a couple he's he's a
kid when you meet him you're like I
don't think he likes me man yeah yeah
you know he's so quiet but you really
turn on the ball busting on camera
camera
like you could anyone could be on the
internet you know like don't talk to
anyone so you could kind of be whoever
you want to be right and then in real
life you be who you are I've made the
mistake of being myself at all times and
it's been very detrimental I mean it's
working out I guess so you're selling
Eight dollar sandwiches on the posts
yeah yeah and he could tell me if it's
working out uh what's your favorite
because you are a sandwich King coach I
appreciate it I mean you you do you you
I've seen you try and showcase all kinds
of food on your insta but sandwiches
really are the main Supreme yeah what is
your favorite sandwich of all time
period
from any place or just like if I'm I
think like I would say I would say
because The Next Episode by the way just
to tease it
kuji is going to stay with us and so is
our upcoming special guest and we are
going to have a fiery debate on the next
episode we shoot today which is going to
be cold sandwiches versus hot sandwiches
which I can't wait to argue this oh yeah
because Joey I'll get into it I don't
want to waste anything but I'm excited
about that that's a teaser but I would
say
it's a two-folded answer tell me your
favorite sandwich of all time and then
tell me your favorite like no the the
such and such at the so-and-so you know
I think my favorite sandwich it depends
what mood I got I got a cup you know
cold cuts very salty so you got to be
really into the mood for cold cuts so
let's take it one level higher before
you answer this all right favorite type
of sandwich
which is a big umbrella then in that
category favorite sandwich then
specifically this place you see what I'm
saying so favorite type would probably
be like overall
it's gonna have like a chicken cutlet in
it I think that's Top Dog okay so like a
hot Italian style chicken cutlets so
okay that's just like the basic like the
go-to you don't know what to get so you
just get a chicken cutlet Bijou much
roast red peppers maybe throw broccoli
raw maybe glaze on there on a hero what
kind of glaze balsamic all right what
are you doing is there any other glaze I
got I got news for you I find balsamic
to be a disgrace and it turns the bread
it turns the bread brown and I hate it
really bothers me if you know how to use
it see I used to make sandwiches for a
long time I've been in the game for
years okay you gotta when I used to put
like the vinegar I used to lettuce on
the bottom and then you throw the
vinegar or oil on the lettuce I never
liked it on the bread because it would
only be good for next 15-20 minutes
after that if you're soggy it's gross
nobody wants that right so you got to
throw it on the lettuce maybe on the
meat and not too much the only thing
that goes on the bread would be like a
mayo-ish kind of deal see that's always
been my problem with the balsamic over
regular vinegar our other guest is here
by the way he's about to come in in a
second uh he's out there he's shooting
us we're shooting him I mean it's going
in every direction right now
uh that's always been my problem with
both I I gotta tell you I got a problem
with vinegar on a sandwich you don't
like acid on a sandwich I didn't say
that I I think our second guest is here
and then I'll get into this what I was
about to say welcome back to the Pod
ladies and gentlemen he was so good the
first time I wanted to experience it for
myself because I wasn't here Robert
Kelly is in the house hi buddy how you
doing what's up brother nothing I'm uh
first of all uh you got to clean this
place up there's a bunch of spiders it's
kind of gross
he's referring to the Halloween
decorations everybody I mean you don't
want to
decorate a restaurant with spiders and
cobwebs
bar not a place we are a bar all right
wow a kid gave us a bad review the other
day because we didn't have weight table
service he was like I don't like that
you got to go to the bar in order really
I came down here as a no-pressed network
fan to support these guys and I expected
weight staff that's what he said yeah
well that's what we created with a bunch
of [ __ ] that had their moms bring
them breakfast every morning yeah I used
to go get a bowl of cereal and by myself
I I remember I lit myself on fire one
day making tea for myself
in second grade I let you know the
onesies I lit my onesie on fire it just
went wow all the way down to my toes
what were you doing oh the gas stove
yeah I had tea we had tea did you burn
yeah well I burnt my onesie
[Laughter]
my wife calls my penis the onesie goes
in once and she's like take it out how
you doing buddy nice to meet you good to
meet you big fan brother thank you thank
you
um we're talking here cooge we just
brought up we so I'll ask you the same
question once um we're done he's done
answering his oh yeah
folks dog of a time I'm doing my new
one-man show I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden all over the place November 8th
for the New York Comedy Festival here in
New York New York on December 8th uh we
are doing we'll see you in hell live in
St Petersburg Florida but then on the
9th and 10th I will be doing the one-man
show I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
uh Austin Texas January 13th and 14th uh
January 20th and 21st governors in
Levittown we are adding new dates all
the time for venue info and tickets
Please go to jodarosainfo.com also Joey
roses is now open seven days a week
starting at 11 30 a.m every day
the man was too high had to expand hours
expand days come on out and see us seven
days a week 11 30 a.m every day
joeyrosesnyc.com
all right guys the Impractical Jokers
are back on the road after three years
we just announced the tour is called the
drive drive drive tour tickets are
available
impracticaljokerslive.com all cities
across the country we start off in
Pittsburgh at the PPG Paints Arena we'll
be coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island so
on and forth so forth everything's on
sale right now and then uh that starts
in February before that my only two
months left of touring are November and
December November uh 11th Knoxville
November 12th two in Atlanta Georgia one
just sold out says you want to get
tickets get it to the second show 13th
November 13th in Alabama and then we got
November 18th in Louisville and November
19th in Evansville December will be
California and Florida check it all out
right now at savocano comedy.com
everything's on sale merch is available
there for everything pick up some merch
I'll see you on the road
but basically I asked him what's your
favorite so it's National sandwich day
that's the topic for this episode gotcha
uh
i t I asked him what's your favorite
type of Sandwich the umbrella the top
yeah then under that umbrella what's
your favorite kind of that kind of
sandwich you know what I mean the
specific and then finally where's your
favorite place to go and get that
sandwich okay so he said
he said his favorite type of Sandwich
broad umbrella was chicken cutlet oh
good one he said underneath that he goes
specifically with the proscoup usually
in a mutz and then he said
sometimes he likes balsamic vinegar on a
sandwich I said that's a disgrace
okay he said he asked me he goes you
don't like a a acid on a sandwich
this is where I was when you walked in I
do like acid on a sandwich I feel there
are so many things you can add to the
sandwich though to give it the acid you
can add pickled peppers pickles
themselves salt and vinegar potato chips
give me a a thing on the sandwich that
enhances some experience balsamic
vinegar is like what an aunt would put
on a sandwich it's like what like a a
middle-aged woman star in a magazine
yeah you put the Buns man or man be fair
all right middle-aged man too but I mean
it's that's out of a magazine the only
vinegar you should put on a sub is the
the light one what's the what's the you
want a little red wine red wine vinegar
by the way if you use red wine the right
way it doesn't do to a roll what
balsamic does to it oh the balsamic
ruins a roll yeah well it's like
gasoline yeah
a red wine will will but you gotta add
more oil than red wine you put the red
wine then the oil then the salt and
pepper yeah I'm not Furious if there's a
little red wine vinegar on a sandwich I
can deal with it I prefer again to have
a Pepper or something that brings that
flavor in but so so but finish we
sidetracked big time on that where is
your favorite spot to get that because
we we are bringing a chicken cutlet into
the Joey Rose's Family I will not say
what it will be yet okay I know what
it's going to be and it's going to be
pretty goddamn good but it better be but
you I know what it's not going to be
what hot
no but that's for the next episode all
right whatever
[Laughter]
not too shabby you're like that I can
cross my legs like you know I don't like
that you don't like that I can be all
alternative Kelly like alternative
you're doing it I don't like the
attitude it brings you out of you I
can't stand it I hated everything you
just did you were doing this like you
were swirling a drink oh my God if I had
a drink maybe I'd swirl it what is this
place it's a bar I haven't been off on
anything
here God do I love your outfits I didn't
touch this I poured a little on my
coffee I swear to God that's it I drink
I don't care about you
um I got more sandwiches coming out we
got two we got a couple right here that
we're gonna eat but uh but for now okay
so where's your favorite place to get
this type of sandwich that you're
talking about all right there's like two
places maybe three
tree
so I think I fell in love with it at
Royal Crown style in Italy
very good good cut they have I know
you're not big into the Boston but
they're balsamic glaze you'd leave your
wife full I'm just saying all right
that's drawing it out there I leave my
wife for a regular glaze I'll leave my
wife for some peace and quiet
I leave my wife for a Lay's potato chip
like an open bag that was you open in
the 20s still it's like seven at night
they've been open all day yeah those oh
that's so funny I feel like I'm in a
Mobile Police Unit right now with this
neighborhood
we're down and you're down the hip Hood
this is where you're going to start you
start dressing like this you got to hang
out down here
no I do but you come in here dressed
like Pete Davidson this is the
neighborhood you gotta hang out in you
can't hang out and West however the hell
you live this ain't a suburb job this
ain't a West chest outfit no dude this
is like you got this is like Little
Italy like you know this is how you do
it now all right all right good
Crown like the soda that's what RC soda
stood for no [ __ ] Yeah the more you know
uh
I [ __ ] love you this is this is you
right this is you this is kind of this
is it you're not like Jim Norton doing
and Chip chipperson this is you lost me
I don't know it makes me happier
I love you more now oh cool you use one
I don't know who that is when the
cameras go off he won't say a word to
anybody yeah there you go I keep it for
the camera
I love this guy uh you'll be like hey
you want to hang out sometime he's like
yeah yeah man let me know
[Laughter]
um but anyway uh I will crown for the
18th time and then we got
Anthony and Sons Panini shop Sabino shot
I love sabino's Place shout out shout
out to sabima Anthony and Sons
Claires Williamsburg Brooklyn quality
sandwiches quality bread they have
really good mozzarella over there if you
like motzi homemade yeah I went to
sabinos once
uh I'd been there years ago but since we
met to the whole Crow with all you guys
that we went back me and Paul Italia my
business partner here cool we went in I
ate two entire subs from there in the
car parked outside disgusting I was dude
it was like we were just coming out of
the lockdown so I just you know I did
what I had to do uh I think Omicron was
just sort of starting to fade I was I
was in a different place back then
anyway I love you blaming diseases
[ __ ] Fatso in a parking lot dude
there was a lot going on isn't that sad
when you eat like when you have I had
somebody with me I had a dear friend
with me and I still ate like I was alone
that was so sad
all right I'm sorry so sabs and what's
the third place Rossi's Royal season Sun
that's in Poughkeepsie Rossi inside
that's probably one of the top delis you
know in New York no [ __ ] The Kipsy I
think I follow them on Instagram quality
okay it's like real old school a bunch
of like
real Italians bald-headed guys looks
like they could beat the [ __ ] out of you
okay just slowing in sandwiches all day
long wow all right great I love it I
love it now let me ask you sure what so
start with the umbrella favorite oh type
of Sandwich meaning Hoagie or something
on Rye or whatever then specifically in
that category your favorite and then
finally where you love to get it okay
I'm gonna say this can be very
controversial okay because this one city
it's their claim to fame and I think
it's it's not
Chicago no [ __ ] not Chicago what the
the the beef sandwich they dip into yeah
dipping the gunk a bread of bread [ __ ]
off I gotta tell you I like I love
Chicago I love everybody I love Chicago
too that beef sandwich leaves it's got
too many like sprigs of and twigs and
[ __ ] in it there's so much [ __ ] man it's
like yeah they don't decipher the sauce
they don't they don't like strain it and
then they to take a a piece of bread and
wet it is
disgusting I can't wait for the hate
comments about this by the way the most
man I've ever seen the Opie and Anthony
audience ever I was on with Patrice one
morning
and we started [ __ ] on cities food
yeah and he was going cheese steak go
[ __ ] yourself Philadelphia cheesesteak
stinks you should all deep dish pizza in
Chicago we shoot on barbecue to people
it was it was when people called in oh
people the phones were lit up people
were going you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about they were people were
losing their minds it was so funny dude
I'll tell you right now a steak bomb
from uh de blasi's in Everett steak and
cheese steak you just said three things
I don't know any of what any of it is
New York Boston okay Boston is a better
steak and cheese than Philly oh [ __ ]
shut up I mean I'm looking where's the
camera I look at that camera I'll look
at this camera Boston has a better steak
and cheese than Philadelphia all right
I've been there okay listen too bad they
won't let you back in Boston with those
rose-colored glasses that's a homophobic
that city is
[Music]
see Boston has great subjects you think
you could sit like that Boston I
couldn't sit like this four months ago
what are you talking about let me enjoy
my life you [ __ ] thin [ __ ]
excuse me folks let's talk about one of
our sponsors Noom boy I love these this
this Gang This Crew good people over at
gnome I got a guy to my left here you
can't see him but I can see him
and you can't see him because he's so
thin why is he so thin because he didn't
know him he did know him Noom is a
psychology based approach to dieting
it's a lifestyle approach I love what
Noom is doing people want to get the
number on the scale down how do they get
it down they get it down by depriving
themselves they get it down by uh
thinking they have to do a very
stringent exercise regime they get it
down uh by by uh you know doing diets
that they can't keep up because they're
too demanding they get it down in all
sorts of ways I get mine down through
stress uh you know and and waking up at
4am every night but that's not healthy
either my point is folks is Noom is
going to teach you
why you eat certain things what your
relationship to those things are and why
it's better to eat certain other things
I just really really really like the
approach they're doing because every
person has a different journey and a
different goal so your experience to
weight loss should be catered to you
instead of demanding the same strict
regime and drastic changes for everyone
Noom is going to give you a personalized
program that empowers you to build
sustainable habits that's the key word
Sustainable New weights approach is
based on principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy I'm a big fan of the
old CBT it's great it works I've lost a
lot of weight doing it in the past and
that's going to help you better
understand your relationship to so if
you're done trying everything to lose
weight try new weight go to noom.com
slash tastebud that's singular that's
n-o-oom.com tastebud
and sign up for your trial today check
out noom's first ever book also the new
mindset and that's a deep dive into the
psychology of Behavioral change
available for pre-order wherever books
are sold hello fresh hello making the
meals for you easy to make so you can
make your life easier and delicious you
get it folks
you know what hellofresh is doing I
don't need to explain it to you I've
heard it all before but I'm going to
explain it anyway the holidays are just
around the corner
hellofresh makes it easier for you at
this crazy holiday time of year with
Chef crafted recipes and pre-portioned
ingredients delivered right to your door
so you can spread your holiday cheer by
having less time to focus on that
go out there be be the holiday Cheerio
you always want it to be folks and
that's not a plug for Cheerios I'm just
talking here all right save some money
on dinner hellofresh put it towards your
holiday shopping maybe okay as your
calendar fills up as it does at the
system at this at this time of year uh
in this season you can count on
hellofresh to get you some of your free
time back by making cooking simple and
quick these are pre-portioned meal kits
what more can I say top billing just
like giz you hear what I'm talking about
people so go to hellofresh.com tastebuds
and use the code taste buds six five for
65 percent off plus free shipping again
hellofresh.com
tastebud65 and you're gonna use promo
code taste bud 6.5 for 65 off plus free
shipping you can't beat it all right
please hellofresh check them out they
are America's number one meal kit
sorry so okay so steak and cheese is
your favorite type steak and cheese
favorite type of sandwich
now now so I would say I would say
Everett has one of the best steak and
cheese sandwiches of all time and the
place is called shout it out the blasies
the blasi's yeah
now but just in between those two things
I believe that's the name I'm a little
confused how do you how do you dress the
middle part no you do not you get first
of all tell me the cheese tell me the
topic whatever do American cheese of
course you don't do the parmesan because
the parmesan doesn't have taste when
it's melted I don't like parmesan and
like sandwiches
it regular but once you melt it it's not
there's nothing American cheese that
awful white white American right what
are you racing Jesus Christ why the
American cheese I don't like the the the
orange the white guy's mouth a little
bit thank God you didn't say the yellow
it would have sounded more racist yeah
good the Native American American cheese
I was in uh
I remember I was in Europe and I go can
I get American cheese though they go we
just call it cheese oh really yeah it's
just cheese it's not smart
people that say I'll say to people
they're American cheese is the unsung
hero of sandwiches I mean it's just it
bad it's it's batting people go American
cheese is disgusting whatever and then
you go what and it goes with everything
and that's the thing but you realize
when people say it's gross you're like
the only kind they've ever had is like
craft singles they think that's what
American is like no go get Lando Lakes
creamy sliced fresh not too thin though
not too thick either not too thick
either no but if you get real thin then
the [ __ ] slicer gets full [ __ ] up
the deli work is mad at you he's gonna
spit in the [ __ ] cheese that's no
bueno no no I agree my buddy pointed out
once about Land O'Lakes cheese
I remember we were we were it was more
in college we were really high and we
were eating it and we got we were going
so good so good and he goes you know why
you can taste the salt
and that changed my life with Lando like
so I was like that is why it's good you
can taste the salt in it don't forget
the hot Indian on the front on the
[ __ ] labor oh yeah he took her off by
the way yeah no [ __ ]
I had a sex dream one night about her I
came in where is your mind you're out of
control I was on the river that she was
doing laundry
and I came in and I came in and we
started making love making out on the
river she's in a little outfit I had to
take my little Confederate hat off and
then and then I woke up making out with
my wife I was like oh [ __ ]
so we have sex and I was like I was just
having sex they should call Land O'Lakes
native american cheese because there was
a Native American woman on it you can't
do that no I just can't have it it's
gone is that bad yeah all right we had a
[ __ ] Native American no no not her
being on it I mean calling it she didn't
even look Native American she looked
like a white chick she did White actress
Brooke Shields with a feather and Jesus
with a feather in her head the uh
uh okay but here's the thing with that
the steak bomb the steak the steak why
it's called steak bomb because it's
everything all right so that's what I
was asking like hot peppers
peppers onions hot peppers mushrooms
they fry everything on the grill first
then they mix the steak and the peppers
and everything then they mix the cheese
they melt the cheese on top then they
scoop that whole thing into the bread
okay lakash's bread like a like an
Italian soft a little heart on the
outside soft in the middle right and
then they put hot hot but the you know
the the
the hot oil you know what I mean not the
flakes the wet hot pepper I'm gonna take
you guys down to I gotta take you guys
down on a road trip we got to go down to
Philly
and we got to go to John's Roast Pork in
Philly I hear it's banging it's I've
been there
roast pork is nuts but they got a steak
in there and trust me when I tell you
never in a million years would I think
to put these things on a steak
I would go you're nuts it's American
cheese only that's it
they get a steak in there that they put
provolone cheese on and they sliced
tomatoes fresh and put the tomatoes on
it this thing
it One's best sandwich in Philadelphia I
don't hate that dude sounds good it is
so good all right so I'm gonna tell you
what else the last thing I put on that
good mayonnaise
okay mayonnaise
thank you a smear of mayonnaise and what
it go when it mixes with the hot pepper
juice
it cools it down a little bit right
listen I like hot peppers and Mayo
sometimes on an Italian sub but I don't
like it too Mayo on it once in a while
wow what are you doing are you [ __ ]
me listen man it was like the only one
listen that doesn't go on in Italian my
Lord if you get if you get the Phillies
a type of get it out let it out because
I'm gonna look at you after when you're
done with this I can't look at you I'm
the Italian hoagie master I mean Italian
mine okay so my pick is Italian hoagie
first of all you're going in a hoagie
instead of a hero that's red flag that's
what it's called in civilized America
[ __ ] New York buddies I call these
things Hoagies till the day I die
it's a hero it's a song a sub you're
both wrong it's a [ __ ] out of here it's
a submarine sandwich
to stop moving the [ __ ] Navy yeah
yeah dude it's a subject it says
submarine sandwich The Three Stooges
that's how they would refer to it I got
a nice submarine sandwich I'm hungry
Italian hoagie is my favorite sandwich
of all time yeah
Italian hoagie with provolone obviously
no lettuce tomato
it's Louis Gomez too oh my God no please
don't I don't want him on this podcast
yeah I like this I'd like this podcast
to stay going I don't need to get
canceled that's right you don't have to
edit it
what up Louis by the way the fans in the
live chat are saying uh I feel like I'm
watching the founding fathers of
sandwiches yeah I love it I love it I
love it all right ready Italian hoagie
and then the way you have to do it is
provolone cheese oil only
no lettuce tomato extra onion and it
better not be red onion it's got to be
it's a red onion I like red orange and
sandwiches
white onion white or no I'll tell you
the best onion sandwiches boom boom all
right all right boom that's what we use
here right on Joey I don't think onion
or tomato goes on a [ __ ] Italian what
are you Panera Bread who loses red
onions
[ __ ] you in a Beretta yeah red onion
that's nuts that's a sacrilege yeah
listen brother a red onion does doesn't
belong on a [ __ ] sandwich that's
that's a cheap onion they're not they're
not spending the extra money on the
[ __ ] sweet well I'm a [ __ ] slobber
Monday and I like the [ __ ] onion come
on dude I expect more out of you red
onions
I have called Hoagie places
and said
do you put red onion on it if you do I
don't want onion and if you do do you
have white onion in there that you use
for other things and if they go yes we
do I go can I please have the white
onion instead of The Red Onion if you
would still kindly do that for me if not
no onion please all right red onion is
bitter it's it it's okay it's it's it's
it stinks in the wrong way in my opinion
red onions I like a nice a good Italian
hoagie you should smell like Bo it
should be it should be dank what meat
you put in there here's what an Italian
hoagie should be ready if you don't say
the one meat that I know I'm Gonna Leave
Jenna with salami gotcha deluso Cappy
ham and that's not Gaba gold that's ham
Cappy those are two different things we
used to use ham Cappy here at Joey roses
but because of all these damn supply
chain issues you can't get ham Cappy
anywhere anywhere anymore so we had to
change the recipe
Mortadella and regular ham boom boom
boom regular ham regular ham plus Cappy
ham plus Genoa
about the Della you don't have to have
the regular hand but I like matadella
instead of regular hair no but I
prosciutto an Italian sub no way it's
too salty it gets in the way one little
hey don't no no no no no not on an
Italian sub I love proscute I was
well that's ham Cappy is a spicy ham
yeah I don't even need ham Cappy genuine
Mortadella that's all you need
yeah I agree with three and and uh and
once in a while yeah when I get a little
bug up my ass I'll go you know what put
mayo on it with hot cherry peppers
and I like the way that that Vibes
together I really do now if you're
getting I would never put mayo against
prosciutto no you can't do that it's
disgusting I would never put mayo
against even a superstar I wouldn't do
it no but the meats I'm talking about a
little mayo sometimes that's got a nice
bullet uh and then a favorite place to
get it
uh that's tough because there's been a
lot of Hoagie shops in my life uh over
the years I'm not gonna say my own place
because that's cheap right no but you
could say yours
all right Joey roses we do it right
why would why wouldn't you say yours
that's how we make our diet stuff our
Italian sub is calling it down is called
the Dad it's olive oil provolone ham
salami mortadell uh tomato sweet onion
salt pepper oregano hot cherry peppers
boom I like that oregano Oregano's nice
on a sandwich yeah it's great dude it's
great it adds a little something you
know what I mean how is I mean I got
other share which is coming what the
Dell is one of the best Meats I mean oh
dude it's fancy is it illegal in some
places or something like am I crazy
where the [ __ ] is your head nice
it's got fat pistachio on it so you know
the we can't eat it but something
happened I forget and it only comes from
one region of Italy right like a certain
Town yeah baloney bologna is it really
no I'm lying I'm serious look it up
somebody is there a thing is there
somebody you want to try a bite of a
sandwich I would love to
something where matadella's made here
it's only one town we got two
vegetarians here I got more coming out
so vegetarians what are you trying to
kill the guy make a bite what is it take
care just take care you don't have to
eat all of it it's a vegetarian sandwich
it's a cheese Hoagie trust me I mean
the other one looks good
you don't think this looks good Alex
cheese sandwiches you know what I mean
my father worked for a living
right here right here right she got
mic'd up I can't believe you wore that
on my show today I got a sandwich I fat
thousand L.A it's called the fat coosh a
little plug-in I don't oh you got your
own sandwich there yeah all right I
would have ripped that off yeah no
that's the only reason why I'm wearing
it all right what sandwiches he get to
eat
this is our the other veg so we're
debuting two vegetarian sandwiches today
once called the Rupert that's that one
and this one's called the sink you can
try both
but I've got sandwiches with meat coming
out too all right all right
I mean to be honest with you this is my
first time at your shop
and this is the first this is what
you've given me
are you mad that it's vegetarian yeah
I'm [ __ ] mad I've been looking at you
goddamn
multiple whatever the sandwiches you got
now you're giving me the Lisa yeah
good right it's vegetarian what's what's
it I'm gonna take a bite what kind of
cheese was in this
that's got uh Asiago and provolone that
one has three cheeses on it's got
American provolone and Asiago you like
it what do we got Mayo I'll tell you
what I'll tell you why I don't like it
you don't like it are you nuts
take the trimmer [ __ ] animal
I'll tell you why I don't like it
you better be like doing a switch like
it's so good I'm gonna eat the whole
thing I'll tell you why I don't like it
why
that's a charcuterie plate on a bun
I don't I I like listen you can't say
you don't like it on camera Bob all
right well hang on one second
all right I love this sandwich my taste
buds exploded when the what don't you
like about this it's a cheese toast
there's nothing in it you got [ __ ]
that's an Italian sandwich with nothing
all right I mean am I lying it's cheese
and vegetables that's a salad
that's a salad yeah but yeah it's for
vegetables do you not eat meat
these are these are the meats that's for
you that's what you'll you'd love this
[ __ ] thing here miss here come get
this it's made for you you would love it
yeah you come over and have give it to
yeah vegetarian yeah
no he's very bad at it listen this is my
first time here I'm very excited to come
here I've been looking at the sandwiches
for a year and he hands me a salad and a
bun
it's just just
let's not lose track of the [ __ ]
podcast dude sorry now this is more my
speed is dead yeah just bring them over
oh thanks man that's good thanks Dave
all right this is what I this is what
I've been waiting right there wait which
year I had the Brussels sprouts ones
good it's got salt for days on it though
thanks man
do you like that one you [ __ ] [ __ ]
guy's not coming up for it
I love it
see here try this one that's [ __ ]
amazing holy [ __ ]
wow we got over there that's a local
that's an army
prize picks folks prize picks your daily
fantasy
app the fun action you're looking for in
Daily fantasy all right you can make
your entries on prize picks you a sports
guy you want to make some entries you
want to do some player projections you
want to get into all that well prize
picks makes it easy for you to do so all
right what do I mean by all this I'm
going to give you example tonight I'm
taking uh so and so from the Phillies to
throw uh a bunch of fastballs look
people I'm not gonna pretend like I know
what I'm talking about with sports you
know I don't know what I'm talking about
with sports but that's one of the things
I like about prize picks they make it
easy for a sports illiterate dummy like
me to have some fun with the fantasy uh
on a daily basis I enjoy it I really do
do I like sports uh hey sports are
sports they're they're you know whatever
do I like the action I like the action
and I like the fun and I also do find
that there are sporting events out there
that do pique my interest uh more so
than some of the traditional things do
and that's where price picks for me
really comes in handy they are hitting
you with all kinds of events and leagues
and whatever you want to call it from
around the world I like it I think it's
really cool it's easy to play uh it's
just it's just fun it's fun and when you
win it's fun even if you don't know
sports that much you
folks you're not competing against other
people which I like you know that's what
I hate about Texas Hold'em I feel like
you're playing against the other player
I don't like it I like me against myself
that's why golf is a good game
and I stink a guy off
it's you versus the projections at prize
picks all right and you got safe and
fast withdraws I like that too because
if I'm gonna win give it to me baby give
it to me anyway listen download the
prize pick app and go to or go to prize
picks.com and sign up and play The Daily
fantasy Sports
uh first-time users you get a hundred
percent instant deposit to match up to a
hundred dollars with promo code taste
buds if you deposit a hundred dollars
that means price picks will give you a
hundred dollars if you deposit fifty
they'll give you 50. you get it don't
forget enter promo code taste buds at
sign up for an instant deposit to match
up to one hundred dollars
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
folks let's talk about better help real
quick uh I I love better help
um I I truly think they're doing the
Lord's work if you believe in that sort
of thing they're doing the universe is
where you work if you're more of that
kind of spiritual person and if you're
not spiritual at all they're just doing
good work all right uh we all suffer
from anxiety we all suffer from problem
solving or how to solve these problems
in our lives and I feel like we get
stuck focusing on those problems instead
of the solutions
especially now it's been a trying period
for a lot of people in this country uh
and around the world uh we've been
through a lot and we're trying our best
to figure out how to assess problems and
how to solve them and if you focus just
on the problems you can't focus on the
solutions and better help is here to
help no pun intended with that
uh I was initially inspired to to try
therapy because of anxiety and stress
it's just something I've had since I was
a kid uh and therapy did help me over
the years but the way that better help
is providing you uh an outlet for
therapy is really truly what makes them
unique okay uh they're they're just a
great option because they're convenient
they're accessible they're affordable
and it's entirely online that is all the
key stuff you need here and what makes
better help different you're going to
get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and you can
switch a therapist at any time which is
great because therapy can be like any
other relationship you might just
outgrow one another
I'm telling you they're doing everything
right so
if you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there and
better help can help you so
betterhelp.com taste buds is where you
want to go today
you're going to get 10 off your first
month that's better
help.com taste buds
a question for uh wow for Bobby but in
all the years of knowing Joe and o a and
all that did he ever show signs of being
such a great sandwich maker did you do
they know the story between us what we
used to do no tell the story Pam can you
ask me that me and Joe used to live
we were neighbors for years and what we
would do during the day
is we would go to three different places
and we'd pull a
what we call it the uh oh pulpa
Greenwich Village
where we would talk what we did anyways
we'd be yapping about [ __ ] bitching
Justified anger resentments you know
things about this comic of that comic or
a chick so why whatever and we go to
this place and get bread we go to that
place and get Meats we go to this place
and get like sides and then we go to the
park we'd spread it all out and we'd
make sandwiches and he would he would
put the sandwiches together
like Paulie and uh and he'd [ __ ] uh
hand me my sandwich and we'd have our
sandwiches together and we'd switch it
up a bunch of times remember we went to
the Amish Market that was the main one
that was the main one we got most of the
stuff and then we'd uh we make
sandwiches all the time because we
didn't you couldn't find a good sandwich
place there's no good sandwich place so
we just made our own right
what's this other one I'm gonna buy the
local the local oh this sounds good
that's the Army that's out of control
yeah two salamis it's out of control all
right and here's why this that sandwich
is good the salami is not thick yeah
it's not it's really slice everything
paper it's almost like butter it's got
to be see-through it's it's almost like
butter we slice everything paper this is
uh this is the one that's turkey and
roast trust me turkey and roast beef
American cheese you've never had a
Boston roast beef sandwich have you
I've got a steak like a Mike's Roast
Beef no
dude
your dick will fall off well it's roast
beef is so good the wind the wind Casino
opened up shop across the street and
they said we want to buy you and put you
in the casino we want to buy the land
you're on and then put your shop in the
casino and they went go [ __ ] yourself
that's how good this this roast me
places fair enough
for you guys where do you think the best
meal you ever had was wow the best meal
yeah
where's that coming from I know I know
that you guys are all such food experts
well
[ __ ] Elementary
wow this is [ __ ] nuts you love it
right no this is nuts Miss what did you
think of that cheese Hoagie by the way
where'd she go
how many marones
you love it don't you thank you very
much yeah she's a vegetarian because
it's good
you eat seafood eggs so you're not a
vegan you're a vegetarian is that like
pescatarian or something
no but that sandwich was made for you
right
that's made for you that's why I'm glad
you're enjoying it that's awesome I just
don't want a salad in a bun
you know what I mean I'll just get a
salad if that's the case this roast beef
you yeah yucky
this is amazing to me
sit down all right you got three you got
three halves here how you doing actually
wait take that one because you bit it
already wow like an animal that's
[ __ ] good all right what do we got
here all right so you love it this is
the two salami one that's the Army have
you had that one yet no you spilling on
your pants the bread is the disgrace
huh
the bread is nuts we baked the bread
fresh every morning yeah huh yeah you
like that you like that it makes me such
it makes me such gives me such joy to
see you guys enjoy the food dude that
sounds
um I'll tell you the the very different
but that first one is off the [ __ ]
charts the Army yeah I knew you would
like that he's got enough oil in it too
I like I like I like a lot I like a lot
of oil
all right
just enough what uh when you do you ever
do this with sandwiches because I do
this what
I had to stop doing this eat them eat
naked well of course what are you on
only fans no I'm thinking about it when
I fall off you're gonna see my Brazil in
a hot dog buns
these guys carrying the worst mattress
ever made there you go over under 10 000
best folks this is my favorite thing to
do
with a sandwich
all right yeah excuse me
if I'm gonna do it myself
this is my favorite thing to do and I
want to hear what your favorite things
to do are with sandwiches but you'll
you'll get what I mean with that
question when I tell you yeah
I go to the supermarket
I get two crusty rolls from the ones
they bake in in the market you know what
I mean two Kaisers
uh maybe three
I go to the Lunch Counter the deli
counter I get
quarter pound of American quarter pound
of Swiss
quarter pound of ham quarter pound of
turkey quarter pound of Bologna quarter
pound of salami if I was working quarter
quarter quarter yeah [ __ ] blow me
that's very aggressive it's kind of cute
all right it's not very aggressive some
of them I might get half pound but like
right and make it worth it then I get
then I get one of the giant pickles
that's in the barrel okay and then I get
a pound of potato salad and I go home
I take all of those meats and I put them
out on a platter two different platters
together I sliced the pickle long ways
I get I get mustard and I sit out with
all of it and I got the rolls and I sit
in front of the TV and I take and I just
make these monster sandwiches this is
why you're not married
this is why you're alone because no girl
whatever they're like what the [ __ ] how
good this how good you know oh you know
how I top it off my wife would slap me
in the head if she came home and saw me
eating all that [ __ ] meat of course
you gotta do it when she's gone like the
way Cosby remember when Cosby would do
it when he did a lot of things when she
was gone I don't think I want to do a
Cosby's way yeah remember Claire would
leave and he would like make a six foot
Hoagie with an orange soda but like but
you know and then I get a jug of Simply
lemonade Jesus Christ dude and I sit
there and dude you you put on you put on
your favorite old sitcom or whatever you
just let it play and you eat until
you're tired and then you lay back and
sleep this is not good you lay back and
you sleep what the [ __ ] is this you make
another sandwich we're trying to kill
yourself
probably telling me
you're telling me you wouldn't do
something like that do you know what I
used to work at D'Angelo's Subs as a
delivery guy and I found out that when
you call an order in
uh and sometimes people wouldn't pick it
up
and they would be like uh they didn't
come you want that and I'd be like yeah
and I would get a free sub so what I
would do is around 45 minutes before my
shift ends I go to the pay phone and
order a [ __ ] outrageous sub they had
a thing called The Great Divide and it
was the whole sub roll the whole thing
and you could do whatever you want so I
one time took half cold half hot
meatballs steak and cheese everything
hot on one side and everything called
seafood salad tuna Italian on one side I
had to make the sub right
I came back and it was sitting there and
they go I go are they picking this up
they're like nah they're not picking it
up you want it I go absolutely I went
home I got my underwear I put a towel a
full towel over my stomach and I ate
that in a single chair
and a single chair with it on my lap
you had the nerve
to give notes on my thing you prank
called hoagies in from yes
oh yeah I'm a food addict I mean I was
trying to kill myself you're absolutely
right it was a very lonely time in my
life that is [ __ ] I would have been I
would have been better off doing heroin
oh my God yeah what you got one what's
your like what you're like I used to
work at a deli so
you're in there but there was no calling
orders you had to order at the counter
so I would normally just get another
roll make myself two and then disappear
in the walk-in for five minutes right
and just [ __ ] drowned my sorrows in a
sandwich usually the boss will walk in
what are you doing
call me like a [ __ ] I'm in a porno
down and down a [ __ ] hero
and I'd be like well I'm hungry like
[ __ ] lines down the block all right
I'm hungry I worked at a deli called
Duffy's that was great uh they're closed
now but it was great and um
you gotta you gotta shift you got a meal
at the end of your shift
and I worked morning into early
afternoon so as soon as I got off I got
to get lunch and I was starving
and they let you go make your own
whatever they didn't care they'd be like
you hungry just hit the counter make
whatever you want and there was
meatballs there was hot sausage there
was cold cuts there was everything there
was corned beef you could make corned
beef with coleslaw and and Russian dress
like
and you could just concoct whatever you
wanted they didn't care it was awesome
it was so awesome God that was a good
job man seven bucks an hour plus tips
and all I had to do was drive around
deliver sandwiches from 8 A.M to 1pm it
was the greatest summer job I ever had
in my life yeah delivering food is I
love that kid I would listen to stern
all morning 11 o'clock with it I'd
listen to my own music
tips plus hourly I'd forget the hourly
was coming because the tips were so good
then you get a check every week I was
getting a fight with the boss all the
time because he wanted me to put that
stupid delivery thing on my my car right
just you know I was like dude I'm
wearing a I'm wearing a pullover Poncho
with the logo on it that's enough
I I'm degraded enough I'm not putting a
[ __ ] delivery light up sign on my
nice Maximus that I bought you know what
I mean I had another delivery job I
think I told the story on the show
before I had another delivery job I
dropped fried mushrooms and they rolled
all over the parking lot and I picked
them up and put them back in the thing
and brought it to the garbage because I
was too scared I was gonna get yelled at
it was so late already the order was so
behind did you have a hookup on a
delivery
no I had no I had no real game back then
dude I had a I had this she said she was
27 but I think she was 43. yeah
I remember I go how old are you she goes
27 I almost went you [ __ ] lying yeah
because she looked she looked like my
mother's age you know what I mean pretty
but she ordered a Saab and she showed up
I showed up and she opened the door she
had a negligee on and uh she dragged me
in the thing and we fooled around
and then uh she gave me the sub too
which was great it was a ham salami ham
salami cheese with Pickles she gave you
the sub she ordered she didn't want it
yeah she's wanted a bang that okay she
knew who you were already yeah she used
to go in and get something Patrick
Dempsey movie
that was a Patrick dempsmit you don't
remember now lover boy
who has gotten so much better looking as
he got older oh Dempsey's a stud dude
he's a stud now race car driver his hair
he's always been a good looking kid
though I just watched Heaven Help Us and
that's his first movie I believe
he's a good looking kid remember those
[ __ ] great 80s movies like with
Cusack and him and and who's the redhead
that used to do them too uh Eric Stoltz
Stoltz yeah those romp those dude yeah
they got the hitch in Heaven Help Us you
ever She haven't helped us what's that
one I know I have it's about Catholic
school kids in Brooklyn in the 60s it's
great oh really but the the main three
kids it's Kevin Dillon Andrew McCarthy
and Patrick Dempsey no [ __ ] I mean they
were they were bagging on all cylinders
when they passed that movie yeah it's a
great flick it's worth watching John
Heards in it Donald Pleasence what do
you guys think of Brendan Frazier's
comeback I love it love it I like him
heavier it's fun I mean look he was sexy
as hell back in the day but I love that
he's a beast now I love it Kush goes who
the [ __ ] is that you know Brendan Fraser
remember the mom you see the movie The
Mummy The Mummy yeah I think so that's
the lead good-looking guy okay yeah he
got his hair kind of fell out and he got
a little chubby look like he got mange
he backed out a little bit had some
problems with his family backed out of
acting came back in he's got a new movie
coming out called Fatso no the whale the
whale same thing
yeah he's got a new movie coming out
it's called tub of [ __ ] it's called Big
Tits McGee yeah but uh but he's no he's
gonna get Oscars for this great actor
good actor he just fell the way of the
the Matthew McConaughey way where you're
good looking and they put you in that
movie where you're making a gazillion
dollars and you're gonna make seven of
them or you're gonna go and leave and I
think he went I think he went bankrupt
at one point yeah well Matthew
McConaughey he was good looking too but
then he went and got ugly dude
how about McConaughey no
dude McConaughey everybody on planet
Earth was ready to write McConaughey off
as yeah your Google can guide it does
bad romantic comedies with Kate Hudson
or whatever it is
and then he comes in and he does like
The Lincoln Lawyer he did the Dallas
Buyers Club that's what it was and then
he hit that guy he doubled down with
that and then he did True Detective
[ __ ] and then Interstellar and literally
was great in like three months we all
went like this guy's a great actor he's
like where is he you gotta get ugly and
then like and that was it that'd be
great now he's like you can't think of
him any other ways you gotta get ugly
you can't be good looking DiCaprio once
the Capri got a little that little booze
blowed on him yeah
yeah [ __ ] good actor now yeah you're
right you can't be good looking as a
male and they all as soon as they hit
that eyes a little [ __ ] Sean Connery
sucked as James Bond as soon as he got a
little older and ugly he became a good
actor Mel Gibson
you're naming guys that have stayed good
looking through their whole career [ __ ]
Mel Gibson looks like [ __ ] right so
pretty hot for her 70 year old man I
don't even what I barely know who that
is I know the name but I can't picture
the face [ __ ] Lethal Weapon do you
have
to relax I'm sorry
you know who [ __ ] Mel Gibson is
[ __ ] 25 what do you want for me that
doesn't matter you should have a
[ __ ] movie but I don't like
know him like I can't name him he
directed a movie about Jesus Christ who
you look very much like yeah
listen guys plug up we're pimp we're
good on time let's move to the next
episode guys make your plugs please and
then we're gonna go into the next
episode which is the battle and let me
tease it it is cold sandwiches versus
hot sandwiches it's gonna be a throw
down we're gonna get right into the
battle on the next one National sandwich
day thanks for being here with us Bobby
you got plugs yeah I'll go to Louis
ck.com get my new special kill box
that's all I gotta plug Kush uh not
really whatever you know who I am
and you got
you got my plug separately so I'm not
gonna do it here again thank you taste
Buddies thank you Tasties thank you for
being with us we'll see you in the next
episode back again with Robert Kelly and
my man cuisine for cold sandwiches
versus hot sandwiches taste buds they
come into the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two Fool's gonna fight but only one
food taste